Donald Trump gave an interview to Fox News
host Steve Hilton after that 90 minute long
CPAC speech on Sunday evening.
And it was actually interesting because Steve
Hilton did attempt to confront Donald Trump
about the riots.
Now, if you watched Trump's CPAC speech, even
though it was 90 minutes long and it covered
a lot of topics, council culture, how Trump
really won the election, how Trump is so popular,
all this stuff, there wasn't a single word
about the January 6th riot.
At the US Capitol that Donald Trump incited
during Trump's 90 minute CPAC speech.
So let's look at some clips here from this
interview with Steve Hilton.
Here is Hilton asking Donald Trump about the
reports that he was enjoying watching the
riots on TV on January 6th.
And Trump sort of weirdly tries to deny that
he was watching it.
But in so doing, he admits he was watching
it exactly as was reported.
Take a listen to this.
That when that was unfolding, you were watching
and actually you liked what you were seeing
because you felt that it was your people fighting
for you.
Do you get how bad it was?
And is there anything looking back on it now
that you would have done differently that
day?
Well, that's incorrect reporting.
First of all, I wasn't watching TV.
I turned it on later on when I heard about
it and did a lot of moving.
So if you listen to what Donald Trump said,
I wasn't watching TV.
I turned it on when I heard about it.
Well, yeah, Trump heard about it while the
riots were going on.
That's when he turned it on.
It's a very strange kind of like denial where
he's actually saying the reports are correct.
And then Trump says he, quote, did a lot of
moves.
I don't even know what that means.
But this answer is so silly.
It's so obviously a lie.
Clearly, Donald Trump watched the riots on
TV, just like everybody at the White House
was watching them.
It would be crazy if Trump wasn't watching
the riots.
Like, what do we think Trump was doing?
Were to believe that Trump went to the rally
at which he incited the riots, went to the
White House.
Everybody at the White House, every news station
is covering the riots, tweeting about the
riots, et cetera, et cetera.
Mike Pence is being evacuated.
And Trump is like, what is Trump doing?
What would he possibly even be doing other
than following what it is that's going on?
So, of course, Trump was watching and he's
like Trump later in the same segment, went
on to try to blame Nancy Pelosi for the riots
somehow.
But before doing that, Donald Trump falsely
claims that hundreds of thousands of people
were at his January 6th rally watching him
speak.
No, but we actually I requested I said, look,
this rally is going to be bigger than anyone
thinks because everybody I see said, oh, we're
going to be at the rally.
We're going to be at the rally.
And it had it was, I think, the largest crowd
that I've ever spoken before.
And I've spoken very big crowds, hundreds
of thousands of people, and more than that,
hundreds of thousands of people.
And more than that, he still can't stop lying
about the same things that he's been lying
about for years.
He's learned nothing.
And then OK now onto blaming Nancy Pelosi.
They should've said no.
From what I understand, they gave it to the
people at the Capitol, which is controlled
by Pelosi.
And I heard they rejected it because they
look so, you know, if that was a big mistake,
do you just want to know how you feel about
it now?
Do you think people want to hear you say that?
I don't know.
I hate to say I think it's terrible.
I hate to see it.
I will tell you that.
It's very interesting, however, when you see
Washington burning and when you see Seattle
burning and Portland burning and all these
other places burning with antifa and the radical
left, nothing seems to happen.
Nobody seems to be bothered by that.
So Trump shifting to antifa, of course, the
January 6th riots happened when Trump was
president.
So did all of those other things that Donald
Trump mentioned there.
Trump then is asked, are you happier without
Twitter?
And Trump says, well, you know, I do have
a lot of free time now because I don't have
to worry about avoiding spelling and grammar
mistakes in my tweets.
And he also mentions that it's not just that
he's happier without Twitter.
His poll numbers are higher than they've ever
been for him or anyone else.
I guess he's saying here, you interpret, if
you can, another report which may or may not
be true, that actually, since you've been
you've been stopped from using Twitter, you're
actually happier to be off Twitter.
And I'm just wondering whether the impact
of your speech today, not being on Twitter,
there's a sort of Trump 2.0 with there's kind
of less is more strategy.
That actually might be something you want
to see.
Well, it could be.
I mean, I have much more time.
I can now speak to you a little bit and I
can do things that, frankly, when you're tweeting,
does take up time and you want to make it
perfect, because if you make a spelling mistake
or you put a comma in the wrong location,
they go wild.
He doesn't know the story.
So, you know, you want to make it good.
You want to make it.
But I will tell you, I do have much more time
in my poll.
Numbers are high.
You know, I think they're the highest they've
ever been.
It's very interesting.
I had when I was tweeting and I know you about
tweeting, too, but I'm telling you, it's sort
of very cool.
I had a lot of people saying I love them.
We love our president, but I wish you wouldn't
tweet.
It's true, so that is that is really something
else.
Another strange interview, my honest assessment
after hearing this interview and also watching
the Sunday CPAC speech.
Is that Trump seems to be kind of going through
the motions, but he seems very deflated in
reality, sort of desperate to have relevance
and political capital, again, he wants to
be kingmaker for 20, 22.
That's why he's announced that he's now fundraising
and you can donate to him to his PAC to help
people get elected or reelected in 2022.
And it seems as though how well that goes
will be a big factor as to whether he runs
in twenty, twenty four.
I have no idea whether he will or won't run
in 2024, but increasingly seeming deflated
and like he's not even really sure that he
wants to stay in politics.
We'll see what ultimately happens.
And I don't know if we're going to see too
many more upcoming interviews from Donald
Trump.